alex alex was alex ich finde es ja
wirklich nett dass du mich eingestellt
hat und so weiter aber ich muss ein
praktikum als grafikdesigner machen
kaffee kochen konnte ich auch vorher
schon durften eine kundenanfrage war
aber ich ja aber das war nichts
besonderes
ich studiere grafikdesign verstehst du
grafikdesign sekretärin wollte ich nicht
werden
ich habe jetzt keine zeit hier klaus
lang partner
mein erster auftrag sie wollen mit ihren
kunden und geschäftspartnern ihr
firmenjubiläum feiern sondern richtig
fettes eventuellen und ich soll das
organisieren ja das ist doch super
das was gar nicht tun nichts
claussen partner brauchen wir erstmal
ein kostenvoranschlag und ich will ein
bisschen ich will endlich was sinnvolles
machen nicht meine zeit verschwenden
davon habe ich zu wenig was fragst du
four wenn ich schon nicht entwerfen kann
dann dann lass mich wenigstens bei der
suche nach einem ort für unsere feier
helfen
meinetwegen dann bin ich mal gespannt
was auf die beine stellen kannst
hallo mal was nein ich bin dein
praktikum heute abend muss ich in den
holunder und dann muss ich eigentlich
auch noch leute bei ihrer kollektion
helfen und eigentlich muss ich auch noch
für meine klausur lernen
aber vielleicht kann ich das auch am
wochenende machen was natürlich will ich
dich sehen mag das ist doch blödsinn
hallo aufgelegt es wäre so toll wenn ich
meine schicht am donnerstag und freitag
verschieben könnte ich schreibe meine
klausur und ich muss noch so viel lernen
das wird nicht gehen die einzige
einspringen könnte ist leonie und gab es
am wochenende aber ich habe wirklich
keine zeit
frauen um die zeit außerdem rumzicken es
muss zuerst mit dem kind sitzen und
jetzt wird sorge weckte meine tochter
haben die blöde tagesmutter macht stelle
urlaub ich will auch mal urlaub machen
aber ich muss doch geschichten schienen
macht spaß herbert schöneres vorstellen
als den ganzen tag den laden hier allein
zu schmeißen
ehrlich ich wusste gar nicht dass du ein
kind heißt
und dass du so viel stress das tut mir
leid
auch wenn du jetzt machst
allerdings einer sache des videos
ich wollte nicht steffen was machst du
denn da noch in dem bono mensch etwas
total kompliziert
das sind chips doch immer sollte das
einen geheimen tunnel werden damit die
fliegen kannst sag mal
was machst du eigentlich wenn du mal
nichtig ist
sag mal hast du trottel gesehen soso
die hat heute früher schluss gemacht